أبلغت كل من أوكرانيا وروسيا عن
قتال عنيف على طول
الجبهة الجنوبية، وتزعم أوكرانيا أن القوات الروسية
أطلقت خمسة صواريخ و 60
غارة جوية خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية، كما
تقول إنها تقوم
بعمليات هجومية في منطقة زابيا وفي
باتوت في الشرق، وتزعم أن موسكو
أرسلت  انضمت قوات النخبة المحمولة جواً إلى
المعركة في زابيا واستسلم أكثر من عشرين
جنديًا روسيًا في
الأيام القليلة الماضية. وتعمل أوكرانيا
على تفريغ الوحدات الدفاعية الروسية
بالمدفعية بعيدة المدى وفي وقت
متأخر مما يحدث على
الخطوط الأمامية.  بالإضافة إلى بعض التحديثات الأخرى، حيث أن
بشير هنا، أولاً وقبل كل شيء،
وصل الرئيس زيلينسكي إلى إسبانيا
في رحلة غير متوقعة إلى حد كبير،
نعم هذا ظهور مفاجئ للرئيس
زيني، وسيشارك الآن
في بعض اجتماعات الجماعة السياسية الأوروبية
مع
مسؤولين ونظراء أوروبيين آخرين سمعنا
من الرئيس زالينسكي بالفعل عند
وصوله يقول إنه هناك لتقديم
مقترحات جوهرية عندما
يتعلق الأمر بتعزيز
الأمن الجماعي في جميع أنحاء أوروبا أوروبا
وبالطبع يرى أوكرانيا كجزء من
مستقبل أوروبا  لقد سمعنا من
مسؤولين أوروبيين يصفون أوكرانيا بأنها
الآن القلب النابض
للاتحاد الأوروبي في هذه المرحلة الزمنية،
وفي الواقع لدينا تغريدة من زالينسكي
هذا الصباح يقول فيها إننا سنولي
اهتمامًا خاصًا لمنطقة البحر الأسود
وكذلك  جهودنا المشتركة
لتعزيز الأمن الغذائي العالمي وحرية
الملاحة هي الأولوية الرئيسية لأوكرانيا
خاصة مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء وهو
تعزيز الدفاعات الجوية، لقد
وضعنا بالفعل الأساس
لاتفاقيات جديدة مع الشركاء ونتطلع
إلى الموافقة عليها
وتنفيذها الآن بالطبع
تعزيز الدفاعات الجوية لأوكرانيا  لقد
كانت أولوية بالنسبة لأوكرانيا منذ
بداية هذا الغزو، وما زالت
كذلك، لذا فإن ما رأيناه مرارًا وتكرارًا خلال
الأشهر القليلة الماضية هو استمرار
هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار من قبل القوات المسلحة الروسية،
والآن تقول أوكرانيا إنها حققت بعض
النجاح بالطبع في إسقاط العديد من الأشخاص.
في الواقع، شهدنا بين عشية وضحاها
محاولات لشن هجمات بطائرات بدون طيار مرة أخرى،
وتقول أوكرانيا إن دفاعاتها الجوية
نجحت في إسقاط 24 من أصل 29
هجومًا بطائرات بدون طيار، بالطبع لا يزال هذا يمثل
أولوية أه بالنسبة لأوكرانيا وقد
تسبب هذا في أضرار بالبنية التحتية ولكن ليس
كثيرًا  أه خسائر بشرية لكن أوكرانيا
تستهدف الآن أيضًا الأراضي الروسية
مرة أخرى لقد رأينا منطقة
اللعنة الروسية تتعرض لهجوم بطائرة بدون طيار من قبل
أوكرانيا وفقًا لمسؤولين روس محليين
يقولون إنه كان هناك بعض
الأضرار في البنية التحتية هناك لكنهم
اتهموا أوكرانيا أيضًا  بسبب استخدام
الذخائر العنقودية في هذه المنطقة، يقولون إن بعض
البلدات الحدودية على طول منطقة KK
تعرضت للهجوم وأن
شخصًا واحدًا على الأقل قد أصيب نتيجة
لجروح الشظايا، ونحن نعلم بالطبع
أن استخدام الذخائر العنقودية العنقودية
إنه أمر مثير للجدل بشدة
بسبب التأثير الذي يمكن أن يحدثه هذا على
حياة المدنيين عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالعواقب وخراب الشظايا الذي
يمكن أن يترتب على ذلك ولكن كما ذكرت
أن القتال العنيف على طول
الخطوط الأمامية لا يزال مستمرًا في أوكرانيا،
يقول المسؤولون العسكريون الأوكرانيون إنهم
يقومون بذلك  التقدم الذي أحرزوه في صد
الهجمات ولكن خلال اليوم الأخير شهدنا تعرض
140 مستوطنة في الخطوط الأمامية
للهجوم ونسمع
التركيز المستمر من المسؤولين الأوكرانيين من
الرئيس زينسكي على الحفاظ على هذا
الدعم ومستوى الدعم الذي
رأيناه من الأمم المتحدة.  المجتمع
لا سيما مع استمرار
تزايد الأسئلة الآن واستمرار تزايد القلق
حول توريد أسلحة الناتو والأسلحة الأمريكية
إلى أوكرانيا